J'suis désolé mais je me sens à l'aise comme ça, et alors ?
La virilité elle est à l’intérieur, pas à l'extérieur !
Ouais heureusement.. !
Ouais, mais j'ai un truc à faire là-bas..
Donc là c'est parti pour la petite scène du vélo. Ça tombe bien je sais faire du vélo !
Et sans les petites roulettes
Donc on va en profiter un maximum avec Natoo
Qui arrive normalement dans heu....
Elle devait arriver il y a une heure
♫ Une petite balade à vélo, avec ce bon Nono ♫
♫ Et pas en pédalo parce que c'est complètement différent , faut le faire dans l'eau ♫
Est-ce que on peux valider la taille de l'érection ?
La belle verge ! Donc on va utiliser une banane pour faire un faux zizi sous le drap
Bah faut juste couper ça ? Faut l'arrondir et puis voilà !
Pour plus de réalisme, c'est plus tendu vers le haut, mais là c'est pour les connaisseurs
Mais Norman qu'est-ce que tu fais !? T'es fou !
Norman : bah voyons il est 4 heures, c'est l'heure du goûter !
En fait je me suis déjà maquillé en meuf et j'ai déjà eu ce problème
Là tu me fais trop une bonasse alors que ...
Nan ! Trop pas !
On dirait que j'suis un vieux mec de cabaret : "Hé tu me mets une bonasse n'importe quoi !"
En place s'il vous plait ! Sans rigoler ! On se concentre merci !
Pardon d'être heureux, pardon de vivre du bonheur !
C'était la scène la plus dure du tournage, mais on y est arrivés ! Psartek
Voilà ! Elle m'a mis une grosse crampe..
Ça ne part plus du tout !
On ne peut plus tourner..
J'vais avoir du rouge à lèvres sur toute la vidéo là..
Je prends les commandes du Making of
Ça c'est Antoine Barillot !
Le réalisateur
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe Norman ? T'as l'air de douter..
La question c'est est-ce qu'on arrose les plantes à l'extérieur ou à l'intérieur ?
Le débat est lancé, exprimez-vous dans les commentaires Youtube
On nous avait dit que c'était la maison des Petits Mouchoirs
J't'ai raconté ça ?
Oui ! Alors info ou intox ?
Hé bah c'est vrai regarde !
Alors ça ! Ça c'est de l'humour !
Mais on a la dame !
C'est pas du tout la maison des Petits Mouchoirs !
C'est la maison du bonheur !
Natoo a tenté de me prendre dans les bras
Mais ça a duré une seconde et demie, voilà elle m'a également cassé un côte
C'est faux, il pèse 30 Kg
Voilà je vais tomber c'est sûr
Je suis vraiment une victime là
T'es un pote chelou là quand même
Norman : Et c'est beau hein ! c'est très très beau
Aller le sable dans les chaussures on aime ça p***ain. Ha je déteste le sable !
C'est le sablier du père Fouras... Blague technique hein ?
Là on s’apprête à tourner le refrain de la chanson, le moment où je suis tout seul dans cette solitude
En train de faire "j'suis dans la friendzone"
Il fait 40.000 degrés, voilà pourquoi j'ai un petit parasol d'homme fragile
Si jamais il se met à pleuvoir d'un coup, j'suis équipé aussi
CHOUCHOUS ! BEIGNETS !
Natoo est une femme incroyable devant la caméra, mais hors caméra elle a des petits problèmes
c'est à dire que c'est une PétoGirl
Problèmes gastriques...
Ha excusez-moi..
Voilà son trip tout le tournage c'était de faire des prouts avec son iPhone
J'en peux plus !
Fin de tournage [cris de joie]
Merci pour ta bague d'amitié Norman !
De rien, j'suis vraiment dans la Friendzone. Allez, clap de fin !